dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir in this work we
place a small light source to a chosen
point in the scene and record a
photograph of how things look like with
the given placement then we place the
light source to a new position and
record an image again we repeat this
process several times then after we have
done that we have the question what
would the photograph look like if I put
the light source to places I haven't
seen yet this process we call imagery
lighting this work uses neural networks
to do relighting by learning how
different light source placements behave
if you haven't heard about neural
networks before make sure to check out
our previous episodes on the topic I
have put links for you in the
description box after the training
this technique guesses how completely
unknown light source setups would look
like in reality we give the algorithm a
light source position we haven't seen
yet and it will generate us a photograph
of how it would look like in reality and
the first question is okay but how well
does it do the job I am not sure if
you're going to believe this one as you
will be witnessing some magnificent
results on the left you will see real
photographs and on the right
reconstructions that are basically the
guesses of the algorithm note that it
doesn't know how the photograph would
look like it has to generate new
photographs based on the knowledge that
it has from seeing other photos it's
completely indistinguishable from
reality
this is especially difficult in the
presence of the so called high frequency
lighting effects the high frequency part
means that if we change the light source
just a bit there may be very large
changes in the output image such a thing
can happen when a light source is moved
very slightly but it's suddenly hidden
behind an object therefore our
photograph changes drastically the
proposed technique uses ensembles it
means that multiple neural networks are
trained and their guesses are averaged
to get better results what do you do if
you go to the doctor and he says you
have a very severe and very unlikely
condition well you go and ask multiple
doctors and see if they say the same
thing it is reasonable to expect that
the more doctors you ask the clearer you
will see and this is exactly
what the algorithm does now look at this
on the left side there's a real photo
and on the right the guess of the
algorithm after training can you believe
it you can barely see the difference and
this is a failure case the success story
scenarios for many techniques are not as
good as the failure cases here these
results are absolutely stunning
the algorithm can also deal with
multiple light sources of different
colors
as you can see machine learning
techniques such as deep neural networks
have opened so many doors in research
lately we are starting to solve problems
that everyone agreed were absolutely
impossible before we are currently over
2000 subscribers our club of scholars is
growing at a really rapid pace please
share the series so we can reach people
that don't know about us yet let's draw
them in and show them how cool research
really is thanks for watching and I'll
see you next time